I've been a fan so long of his uh movie
roles TV roles Criminal Minds now in
season 13 again the latest episode is
tonight at 10:00 Eastern Time
but I also love this guest because he's
a big sports fan and he'll drop names
like the one he just did in their
commercial break like Lee Mazzilli a
friend of joe Montana's who's here on
the rich oh there you go and you know
what Lee it's a funny thing with Lee
when he played for the Mets I mean I
hated his guts because I'm being a Cub
fan and he played a Manny and it would
kill the Mets I mean he bet even mr.
better like 700 against the Cubs and so
and he played the outfield
I'd sit out in the bleachers where I
always said and I'd be screaming it I'm
not only screaming at him but yelling
like Italian epithets like you know
because I think he'd get it you know
sometimes I'm screaming like all these
Italian dirty words at him and you know
he's not looking so so there's no jump
cut but 20 whatever it is 10 15 years
later in Hollywood a friend of mine
didn't dear friend actor Dan Lauria who
happened to be a friend of Lee's because
we wanted to get in acting then and then
give him some acting he just we happen
to be at the same place and Dan goes hey
I brought this friend of mine you know
you probably know my mom is a baseball
player Lee Mazzilli and and I swear to
God when he brought Lee in I thought to
myself oh my god what if he recognized
you know he might I was waiting for that
moment of him you know that's sad in the
bleachers that would a nice to meet you
mr. Montagne Ian I'm like oh yeah and I
just to meet you too late it took me I
mean I think I met him two or three more
times we once we started become friends
before I opened up and said listen I was
that guy in right center that you might
have heard and what was great as he says
how you kidding me he says at Wrigley
Field I never looked up because
everybody was yelling at me that's great
anyway I got to make sure you don't have
rabbit ears when you're when you're in
Wrigley is the opponent Dan Lauria who
obviously many folks know from The
Wonder Years but he was phenomenal as
Vince Lombardi exactly on the odd way
and he I mean he did his baseball to the
show didn't last but the one he played
the was the manager to coach some team
with with the girl picture picture that
was just on Fox yes that so yeah Dan's
great guy and yeah Lee and through him
you know we
become very very close friends Mazzilli
Mazzilli what he would do is up until
last year mm-hmm every year at
Christmastime
he'd send me the Yankees Christmas card
cuz he works for the Yankees
organization though and and the Yankee
Christmas card is like it weighs 15
pounds because it's what it has it has
little metal ornaments you know
designated for all their championship
seasons and and every year I get the
card and I'd open the card it's a yet
another card you won't be getting from
the Cubs show them a picture of the Cubs
Christmas card last year I said okay
we're at worst we're at one now you're
only 26 behind but hey at least you got
that one Joe Montana here on the Rich
Eisen show and I should be wearing
shades right now because you are wearing
and actual real Cubs we're doing I got a
guy whose fall short of saying real deal
though because this leg my assistant was
able to you know I'm sure there's some
kids somewhere like and I don't know in
the Far East that may be hammered this
out but it's like no it's not the real
thing
I thought they handed out these World
Series rings did some of these yeah yeah
I don't know I wasn't on the short list
but it's let's check this out it's got
in size got the goat it's got the
garland got one of these right I mean
they gave you know got this from the
Cubs though right no I didn't okay no
but I you know but until somebody
arrests me for you know this looks
phenomenal for a mojo it's pretty good
it kind of makes me wonder when they all
say you know yeah these things are and
I'm thinking you know who knows they
probably send a couple thousand dollars
to some guy in Taiwan so do you think
you got forward or the only good thing
about it is at least you know it it can
happen if you had asked me this before
last year I would have said no of course
not it's not gonna happen I mean you
know I wrote a plate 30 years ago
bleacher bums that was all about the
whole fact that the Cubs can only take
you so far and there's gonna be that
disappointment but the fact that they
had that magical year makes anything
possible so in other words if they
they if they win now four in a row at
least I could say okay you know I think
all the cup fans will of course be I
don't know if he can create more
excitement than we had last year but but
at least you know what can happen but if
it doesn't happen look I live it I've
lived in Los Angeles for many years now
and that's and they've got a hell of a
team right now so it's not like they're
it's like I said like I said I mentioned
it to you earlier I almost feel worse
for what Cleveland went through because
here's a team that everybody thought you
know should be at the big big big game
here and and they got swept and they get
swept after being up - oh yeah I know
and so that's that's that's almost
tougher to take but the fact that you
had last year is a nice soft landing but
at some point when does the Cubs fan
allowed themselves himself/herself to
get greedy are you there I don't want to
do that you know because like I said my
mother who was who passed away in April
at a hundred and one years old
thank God got cut was able to see the
Cubs win even though when she was born
they were on a 7-year losing streak
so how can I be greedy if I'm thinking
that my mom had to wait through her 101
years to finally see it happen so my
feeling is I'm good for 107 years if it
I have to be not that I would be around
for it but but no IIIi love baseball I
love the sport and so my feeling is at
the end of the day you know may the best
team that year win whoever it might be
it's the Cubs I'll be all the more
thrilled but if it isn't let's let's
have a good baseball enjoy it even if
it's the Cardinals no maybe not the car
[Music]
look I respect the ballclub though they
know I mean they've consistently put put
together a hell of a ballclub it's a
good baseball town so you got to give
that up you know but still it's but when
it comes down to it like I say play
bleacher bums it takes it's a cardinal
Cub game because you have that's what it
has to be it's it right Joe Montana
you're a few more minutes here with the
star and director of Criminal Minds and
also I am NOT a comedian Tom Lenny Bruce
which you directed about Lenny Bruce
it's at Theatre 68 right here in Los
Angeles in North Hollywood theater 68
com4 tickets for that one
ah true Biscay does that excite you just
does excite me yeah I mean I it's one of
those things you just hope it's gonna be
like you know if it's gonna be like a
like a storybook kind of thing the guy
comes in the young guy comes in and
takes over has an impact he reminds me
of like when the that time when they
brought you know like man in at that
Minnesota game and just showed how it's
changed some a little fire get something
going
we'll see I mean the Bears of again
there's a bit of tough load to carry
fryers but we'll see he I think he's
exciting he's got a lot to learn the
past thingee games got improve but first
thing I thought of when the Bears traded
up to get him and I'm not saying this
just because you're here Joe okay is
that when Drew Biscay was drafted by the
bears I thought because you know
everyone's gonna read into him like he's
the the end-all be-all and the other
hole a perfect name for the same thing
what's risky exactly over there and no
ego and finally got a guy who's and they
wins with a ski you know what I mean cuz
he did that they wrote that original
skit da bears for me when I hosted
Saturday live in 91 and then George
Wendt went on to be my brother and we
made a whole meal out of that whole
thing but yeah if you're gonna get a guy
in to play quarterback for the Bears
again are you gonna go with the dims or
the ski you know what a ski and then you
know you got somebody who is a real
Chicago in true Piske ski I mean oh my
god you're kidding me - did like screams
you know pierogies and all those great
things but it's s KY that doesn't matter
we'll take it just here to me as if you
know he's gonna look at Y is too risky
for biscuits dick or dispel the di T's
do you know were to see it snow would
have been better I honestly thought that
on the set of the draft like true Biscay
is a perfect game oh yeah oh no hey if
this guy really has did you know he'll
be cook he could become governor of
Illinois mayor am i doing a jail term
probably governor of Illinois
man season 13 of Criminal Minds Joe I
mean did you think that you'd be
involved in something that running this
long you know yeah like like I said you
know was a big decision for me even to
go to commit to doing networks TV series
I mean I had a fun career doing film
primarily theater and all that and and
God bless Len les Moonves at CBS he
would always every year ask me says hey
you ready to do a pilot ready to do a TV
series and I said you know what I'm kind
of having fun doing what I do but what I
said I hope you're there when the time
comes and he was and it would offer me
these different things and I did this
thing first Monday with James Garner
were in 13 episodes I did Joan of
Arcadia at last the two seasons but then
finally Criminal Minds that opportunity
came up in this great organization great
cast cast crew everybody and you hope
for the best
it's like it's like sports you you you
you get you join the team you hope this
this is the combination that can maybe
take you take take you along and and
it's been that way it's it's been
consistently strong strong all over the
world that's what's great too very
heartening I mean I travel through
publicity for the show people come up to
me all you do you'll know you're Z
number one show in France thank you we
we know that but yes but it's been great
and I'm just pleased that it's doing as
well as sisters doing in this play about
Lenny Bruce why do you want to choose
like this guy named Ronnie Morrow who
runs us the theater 68 in North
Hollywood he's he's been devoting 10
years of his life to researching Lenny
Bruce creating this this this one-man
show and he waited for me says I really
want you you're the guy to direct it if
he would I said look if he can wait for
me I have a little time during my hiatus
this past year I said I'll do it and I
did and it's running it's been running
for about a month months a couple months
now and it's gonna keep running for at
least through November and I think we're
gonna be taking it to New York it's it's
it's got incredible reviews he does an
incredible job it's not it's not just
his act and what it is is he does his
it's his life story with Lenny Bruce and
Lenny was without Lenny Bruce you don't
have Richard Pryor you don't have George
Carlin you don't have any lot of great
comics he paved the way and so anybody
who has an interest in that
I mean I think it's he does an
incredible job just said it's only an
hour and a half one-act it's in NoHo at
the theater 68 I think they'd have a
good it's a great evening of theater
before I let you go how often do you
talk to mammy David you know it's funny
I've known Mamet for over 40 years and
we don't stay in constant touch we never
did it's like one of those things he
knows I'm busy I know he's busier but we
had kind of friendship that if I got him
on the phone right now he'd be there for
me and vice versa and when we do talk we
never talk about business we talk about
you know our kids or sports you talk
words yeah we talk yeah he's he's uh
he's Southside but I think he's if I'm
not mistaken is he still got a soft spot
for the Cubs okay so even though he's
Southside well good luck to your Cubs
tonight sir and yeah it's gonna take a
big one a lot of luck but but you know
they can they can do it they can do it
with the Mojo ring I think mojo ring
check out Criminal Minds tonight 10:00
p.m. Eastern Time right in the middle of
what you are I'm sure hoping not only a
well watched episode of Criminal Minds
but it Cubs win tonight the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience